des chercheurs de l'université
américaine de harvard ont trouvé un
traitement efficace contre la coved
selon le professeur paul mcphun
l'acidité naturelle du vinaigre
permettrait de lutter rapidement contre
les infections des voies respiratoires
c'est bizarre non ça sort affecte news
il faut que je consulte un expert ouais
si tu veux mon avis ça me parait gros
comme une maison cette histoire en tout
cas gros comme mon atelier
comment se fait-on piégée comment ces
fausses informations se propage pas
aussi vite
on décrypte tout ça dans ma nouvelle
vidéo chez jamie avec hugo c'est bien
moi t'inquiète pas on est bon alors go
hugo descat plus pauvres de cette info à
propos du tout vide un traitement à base
de vinaigre
apparemment ça viendra des états unis
des chercheurs américains
franchement ça sent la fox news ouais
j'ai vu passer ça aussi c'est un veau
sur les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs je
crois qu'elle a des centaines de
milliers de partage on parle d'un faux
on devrait plutôt parler d'un fox c'est
le terme officiel d'un dictionnaire
français pour désigner comme ça ces
nouvelles mensongères qui sont
construites de toutes pièces exprès pour
tromper le public
enfin bon fait que muse infox ya
plusieurs terme mais ça veut dire donc
la même chose et contrairement à ce que
l'on pourrait imaginer cette technique
de désinformation ne date pas d'hier
allez je vais citer quelques exemples au
6e siècle l'historien prokop de césar et
rédigé un ouvrage contenant de
nombreuses informations très douteuse
sur l'empereur de l'époque justinien
objectif nuire à cet empereur
un autre exemple on le saisit ainsi avec
un polémiste du nom de pierre l'arétin
lui ne s'est pas gêné pour utiliser
l'effet closes afin de peser sur
l'élection du pape de l'époque il a
composé dé saône et des poèmes pleins de
rumeurs et de calomnies sur les
différents candidats et l'huile est allé
plus loin puisqu'il a collé ses poèmes
sur une statut de rome pour que ces
fausses informations se répandent une
petite dernière pour la route
allez on part en angleterre au xviiie
siècle le royaume uni
les fausses nouvelles sont presque un
sport national il existe même des
paragraphes mène alors ces personnes
sont chargés d'écrire de petits
paragraphes qui ne font en général que
relayer les rumeurs et les ragots comme
par exemple sur les supposées
infidélités de marie-antoinette la reine
de france de l'époque est le point
commun avec les faits news d'aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on peut
retrouver
c'est l'objectif qui est le même tromper
volontairement les gens hier comme
aujourd'hui on utilise donc les faits
que nous pour nuire à d'autres pour
acquérir conserver renforcer son pouvoir
une notoriété s'enrichir ou même
favoriser un groupe d'intérêts la fecq
news peut donc leur apporter beaucoup au
final et le pire dans tout ça c'est que
plusieurs études ont montré que les
fausses informations se propage beaucoup
plus vite que les informations vérifiées
qui sont diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux et par exemple au début de la
pandémie va sûrement vu cette vidéo une
pique news qui a fait des millions de
vues elle affirmait que l'institut
pasteur avait créé le coronavirus pour
vendre des vaccins
alors évidemment c'est faux d'ailleurs
pour la petite histoire l'institut
pasteur n'a même pas réussi à faire un
vaccin au final et il y a une
explication à cette incroyable
propagation évidemment go tu le sais
très bien les fêtes nous ont l'art de
mettre notre raisonnement complètement
ko c'est dans le cerveau que ça se passe
les scientifiques l'ont montré il existe
des failles dans notre mode de
raisonnement
c'est ce qu'on appelle lé biais
cognitifs alors mieux connaître ces
biais permet de comprendre pourquoi on
peut se laisser avoir par les faits que
nous et pour voir ça et bien gauche je
propose de chausser les gants de boxe et
de faire ensemble
une battle effectué aux vraies infos les
gants sont juste derrière toi parfait
allez c'est parti sur le risque alors si
les flics news ont un tel succès c'est
d'abord parce que la plupart du temps
soyons honnêtes nous sommes un peu
paresseux et puis nous sommes tellement
inondés d'informations que tout vérifié
est impossible notre cerveau préfère
donc faire des économies de temps et
d'énergie
et en plus les faits qui nous sont
développées et réfléchie justement
pour nous appâter alors on clique on
partage donc passer à autre chose et
donc la résultat sans appel dès le
premier round et bien fait de nous un
cerveau 0 d'une manière générale en plus
notre cerveau a plutôt la grosse tête
ils surestiment l'ampleur de son savoir
ceux qui propagent volontairement des
fêtes news sont souvent persuadés d'être
suffisamment experts pour pouvoir
certifier que les informations sont
exactes
c'est ce que les scientifiques appellent
le biais de sueur confiance donc la
paresse surestimation on est au second
round et à ce moment là fait qu news2
cerveau toujours à zéro malheureusement
allé troisième round troisième piège
mais dans un monde sûr chargé
d'information comme le nôtre est bien ça
peut poser quelques problèmes
on va faire un petit test avec vous et
moi nous allons vous poser une série de
questions et vous allez y répondre le
plus rapidement possible après au crès
et c'est parti avec la première question
du coût de quelle couleur et le coton
réponse
deuxième question quelle est la couleur
du papier maintenant prochaine question
de quelle couleur sont les nuages
de quelle couleur est la robe de la
mariée et que voit la vache et non la
vache boîte de l'eau pas du lait mais je
vous rassure
presque tout le monde se fait avoir et
c'est tout à fait normal les premières
informations oriente notre cerveau vers
le blanc la dernière question le pousse
à chercher un liquide lié à la vague est
là vim
c'est le lait qui tombe vous êtes
victime du troisième billet qui est de
l'effectif nous à nous embobiner le
biais d'amorçage et là on comprend mieux
pourquoi est ce que les faits qui
n'osent se propage aussi facilement
c'est d'ailleurs intéressant de
reprendre l'exemple du remède miracle au
vinaigre contre le coronavirus cette
fausse information et écrite de telle
manière que notre cerveau va faire un
maximum d'associations avec des idées
comme celle que l'on vient
d'expérimenter ici avec la vache et le
lait par exemple dans cette fac news il
est écrit que ça vient de chercheurs
américains d'harvard harvard 11 du
costume prestigieuse université donc on
devrait tourner en savoir plus tôt
confiance au delà de ça le vinet
c'est quelque chose qui peut être
utilisé comme un nettoyant donc on fait
le lien entre tout ça et on peut assez
facilement croire que le vinaigre peut
permettre de guérir du coc vide donc là
clairement ça nous fait fait que nous
croient cerveau 0 10 mois jamie là ça
commence ce qu'elle va faire plutôt
beaucoup malheureusement je crois que ce
n'est pas terminé
il existe d'autres billets dans notre
cerveau qui renforce la croyance dans
les faits que nous si on prend aussi en
compte le biais de confirmation comme
l'appellent les chercheurs on peut
d'ores et déjà affiché fait qu news4
cerveau 00 notre cerveau a tendance à ne
prendre en compte que les informations
qui vont dans le sens de ce qu'ils
croient déjà si vous êtes déjà convaincu
que le vinaigre est un aliment
formidable et bien vous serez plus
facilement amenés à croire à
l'affectueuse d'un traitement pour ainsi
dire miraculeux de l'aco vide avec du
vinaigre et d'ailleurs au fond c'est
assez logique si on passait notre temps
permanence à remettre en question tout
ce que l'on sait parce qu'on voit une
nouvelle information
eh bien on serait constamment en train
de changer d'avis et en l'occurrence
c'est pas évident c'est dire à quel
point notre cerveau mute contre ce qui
ne lui plaît pas et encore plus si cela
génère en ou de la peur ouais le danger
la peur la catastrophe c'est des lieux
vielles très forts sur lesquels
s'appuient les faits que news c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit au quotidien
l'effet que news joue souvent sur le
sensationnel et en l'occurrence c'est là
où c'est particulièrement dangereux et
le fait d'avoir peur n'ouvrons plus
réceptif à d'éventuels faits que nous
exactement hélas pas vraiment mis dans
le mille
un vrai une percute pour notre système
de raisonnement car là on joue
directement avec la puissance des
émotions contre laquelle il est beaucoup
plus difficile de lutter on a besoin de
se rassurer sur nous mêmes sur le monde
qui nous entoure
des chercheurs du hem haïti aux états
unis l'ont d'ailleurs bien montré ils
ont analysé environ
126 mille tweets relayant de vraies
infos ou défectueuse partagé par à peu
près 3 millions de personnes
ils ont alors observé que les vraies
informations suscitait surtout de
l'anticipation de la tristesse de la
joie ou de la confiance alors que les
fêtes nous entraînait de la peur du
dégoût et de la surprise
résultat les fics n'osant circuler plus
vite et plus largement un pour cent
d'entre elles ont touché entre 1000 et
100000 personnes alors que les vraies
infos ont rarement été partagée à plus
de 1000 personnes
lorsque la peur entre en jeu le réflexe
est de prévenir le plus de monde
possible du danger potentiel
malheureusement sont toujours vérifier
si ce danger existe vraiment on voit
clairement l'effet qu'ils savent
exploiter au mieux nos biais cognitif
pour tromper notre sens de l'analyse et
pour embobiner notre raisonnement
moi même je me suis interrogé avant de
citer toutes les fées kiosque on a
évoqué après tout en faisant cette vidéo
nous parle
une nouvelle fois de ses fausses
informations qui ne cherchent qu'à se
répandre comme une traînée de poudre
et ce même si on s'efforce de démonter
leurs mécaniques et de les dénoncer
eh bien elles finissent quand même d'une
certaine façon par circuler et tu ne
feras pas si bien dire
notre mémoire n'est pas parfait non plus
on va avoir tendance à croire plus
facilement une information juste parce
qu'on l'a déjà vu ou entendu même si
c'était pour nous expliquer qu'elle
n'était pas vrai ce qui rend comme tu le
dis difficile de rétablissement de la
vérité
le risque c'est que plus on parle d'une
fête news plus elle devient familière
plus notre cerveau a tendance à la
croire facilement bongo on va passer
c'est mettre ko son réagir non ce serait
dommage j'avais ce que je te propose
maintenant c'est qu'on fasse un point
sur les différents moyens dont on
dispose pour réagir et se protéger face
au fait qu news nous avons heureusement
aussi des ressources pour lutter et nous
entraîner à mieux faire le tri parmi les
tonnes d'informations qu'on voit passer
tous les jours
la bonne nouvelle déjà c'est que tous
les grands médias aujourd'hui se sont
penchés sur cette question des fakes
news et ont mis en place
est ce un service d' enquête de décodage
ou encore de chasse aux un fox donc on
peut s'appuyer éventuellement dessus et
ne pas hésiter à aller voir leur site à
ouvrir leurs pages ou regardez
d'ailleurs leurs émissions qui font ce
travail nécessaire d'analyser et de
vérification des informations
s'appuyer sur des experts spécialistes
de la traque des faits que nous le
cerveau remporté son premier point
deuxième conseil à la lecture d'une
information c'est important de se
demander qui a écrit cette information
qui a filmé qui a enregistré dessinée
photographier une information qualifiée
elle lehman en général d'un auteur qui
s'identifie clairement au début ou à la
fin de l'article de la vidéo qui est cet
auteur est ce que c'est un expert un
inconnu
quelle est sa légitimité a délivré cette
information est ce que éventuellement il
cite des sources que je pourrai vérifier
quelqu'un qui sort une info et qui dit
que ça vient du cousin de sa tante de
son beau frère je ne sais quoi
pourquoi pas se mentir c'est pas super
fiable c'est un petit peu comme un plat
qu'on vous propose de manger qui la
cuisine et interrogez vous et vous ferez
grimper votre score nous sommes à 5 pour
les fêtes news et on grimpe à 2 pour le
faire pour d'autres questions à se poser
où est publié l'information quels types
de sites
l'éditeur est il un particulier une
entreprise ou encore une association les
son site
est ce que c'est une vitrine officielle
institutionnels ou un blog un réseau
social
l'objectif du site est il de vendre
d'informer de militer de faire peur de
faire le buzz
autrement dit demandez-vous sur quelle
assiette ou dans quel bol au vous
présente ce que vous devez avaler vous y
gagnerez à les bilans du scorff et no 5
3 pour le cerveau on y est presque
enfin de quelle nature est l'information
qu'on vous propose
est-ce que c'est des faits avec des
chiffres des lieux qu'on peut vérifier
etc
où est ce que c'est une opinion un avis
en fait sur un sujet d'actualité
ces deux choses l'information et
l'opinion qui sont très importantes mais
c'est aussi deux choses qui sont
différentes
l'information est basée sur des faits
qu'on peut vérifier et c'est alors que
l'opinion c'est un peu différent c'est
une interprétation des faits
c'est l'image que l'on se fait d'une
certaine information bref questionnez
vous sur le plat qu'on vous sert
histoire de ne pas avaler des salades et
vous éviterez ainsi mieux les
intoxications
ce qui nous fait fait news céreq cerveau
4 allez un dernier petit coup de pouce
un petit dernier pour la route n'hésitez
pas à échanger avec vos amis votre
famille vos collègues de bonnes adresses
d'infos de boo boo contenus
d'information un peu comme on
partagerait finalement des bons
restaurants
pourquoi ne pas essayer de bien se
nourrir aussi en terme de contenu alors
évidemment ça ferait très plaisir vous
pouvez partager à la chaîne des épis
curieux ou la chaîne
hugo décrypte mais vous devez aussi
pouvoir en trouver d'autres heureusement
nos mac à m aujourd'hui beaucoup qui
sont disponibles en ligne
et là je crois qu'on peut faire avancer
le compteur du cerveau passer à 6 5 7 5
mais mozilla effectivement ça fait
plaisir et toi jamais du coup est ce que
tu as des astuces personnel qui pourrait
permettre de compléter tous à oublier
des habitudes de travail quand je
prépare une vidéo que je cherche des
informations je vais toujours aller
récolter auprès de différentes sources
les plus sérieuse possible par exemple
des chercheurs qui travaillent pour des
universités des revues scientifiques
reconnus ou des pages officielles
d'associations de gouvernement et c'est
particulièrement important sur les
sujets que je pense maîtrisait plutôt
que de ne me fiais cas mon intuition ou
à ma mémoire
j'essaie de cultiver le doute de me
remettre en question de faire davantage
confiance aux experts car mon propre
cerveau du coup en fait la clé pour
éviter la propagation défectueuse c'est
donc de prendre le temps de vérifier
l'information qu'on reçoit avant de la
partager
surtout d'ailleurs su elle paraît un peu
inédite un peu surprenantes comme on a
vu là avec la question d'une
gray du coc vide et vous quelles sont
vos méthodes pour ne pas tomber dans le
piège les fêtes news quand vous
êtes-vous fait avoir pour la dernière
fois
dites le nous en commentaires merci
beaucoup go pour ces explique ainsi à
toi et tes conseils
merci d'être venus jusqu'ici dans mon
atelier pour aborder ce sujet des fêtes
news devant mon beau bar kokhba avec
nous
je laisserai jamais à très bientôt merci
et pourant bebon c'est pas mal ça
m'arrive très sommaire le compteur du
cerveau passé à à 506 assez
[Applaudissements]